do you love it out in California with
the legal yeah Colorado - you know what
you've always been legal in Cali if you
ask me what's the thing gummies or all
that gummies and what do you do first of
all that's for [ __ ] [ __ ] no I
don't I don't do [ __ ] we smoke we
smoked it down eat candies and [ __ ]
welcome uh [ __ ] like no I smoke weed
what have you ever smoked with other
celebrities because they seem to get the
strong weed that like knocks you on you
I got a crazy story I got it okay this
is way before SNL just when I was just
doing gigs and stuff and I I got the
chance to smoke weed with Snoop and dine
wine yeah Don Juan Bishop Don Juan and
I'm not paying attention to - Don wine
I'm not paying attention to what he's
doing to the blunts he's smoking them
with his [ __ ] nose why cuz I guess
there's a hole in his nose and he can
hit it I don't [ __ ] know
so he was doing it from one else and I
wasn't paying attention nobody was
hitting that [ __ ] but I wasn't paying
attention your mouth yes yeah
[Laughter]